let's now uh switch i just want to
switch to
a really important strategic part of all
this which is the china part of this
story just look at this headline this
headline after biden's meeting with xi
jinping
she warns biden against sanctions she
warns biden what is this she is putin's
ally he stepped in to buy his energy in
wheat evade financial sanctions now
there's talk of him giving russia the
chinese technology inside the turkish
drones that are doing so much damage and
he's now warning biden she picked a side
and it was the wrong one now we need to
make him pay instead of biden's pathetic
weakness we need to stand up to china
urgently decouple our economies bring
manufacturing home set up a pacific
version of nato and tell our allies they
have to pick a side too germany france
the uk no more sucking up to the brutal
authoritarian dictatorship in beijing
that wants world domination either you
do business with america or you're with
putin and she and good luck with that
here with the reaction the director of
the center on chinese strategy at the
hudson institute and author of the
hundred year marathon china's secret
strategy to replace america as the
global superpower you know him michael
pillsbury um mike there's no one i think
who knows more um and is prepared to
talk about it publicly about what the
chinese leadership is really thinking um
do you think they realize they've made a
huge miscalculation by siding with putin
over this
well steve you and i might think they've
made a major miscalculation but i don't
think the chinese leadership has reached
that point yet
until
the u.s begins to put sanctions on china
so far china has gotten away with it by
it i mean they're the invisible hand
behind putin they're the ones who are
funding the war
roughly half of the russia's gold and
currency reserves are controlled now by
the u.s and by the west you can't get
access to them but the other half the
chinese can provide access to and
they've been doing it they also have the
world's largest credit card now in china
they've allowed everybody in russia who
has this card to charge things the trade
and the purchase of long-term energy
supplies under under uh cut the
sanctions because it shows putin he's
got somebody in his corner for the next
five years or more there's a number of
ways that china's support is just
crucial for putin i believe the chinese
could stop the war with one phone call
to him he'd be like the banker calling
you say steve we're calling in all your
loans that's what putin could have on
the phone from xi jinping so far it's
not happening instead you're reporting i
think very wisely this xi jinping threat
to putin that don't put any sanctions on
will somehow hurt you
exactly i mean it's it seems completely
um you know the wrong way around but
let's just um
fast forward to is there a scenario
where
china is
i mean to our in our sense stuck in this
relationship with putin um the pariah of
the world and there's a block that
emerges china and russia
and let's say sanctions do you know if
we go forward and and look at this real
emergence of the east-west block where
it's china and russia and a few random
countries like iran and venezuela surely
that can't be what she
means and was hoping for in terms of
china's global leadership
no not at all i can tell you that she
and his team tend to be little russia
and putin they're after all 10 times
larger gdp
than
the russians
chinese gdp estimated by the cia
recently as 15 trillion russia's gdp at
best is 1.5 trillion so
the geopolitical balance here is that
china looks down on russia i think they
were told in beijing this will be a
quick operation we'll be in and out of
ukraine
we'll get a permanent pledge never to
join nato please back us but now it's
very embarrassing because the russian
military is stuck
so
probably the only way to get ahead is
going to be american sanctions on china
i think you'll reason you find the
silence from president biden on friday
there's no white house briefing on what
happened in this two-hour phone call yes
so
i have to assume the worst happened that
china was actually quite arrogant to buy
in on the phone call and they're just
not going to help and so the war will go
on because the banker is not going to
make that call and just verify almost
one word answer because we don't have
too much time does all this make a
chinese invasion of taiwan more likely
or less likely
it makes it more likely if they want to
but their game still is to dominate the
world and have double our gdp over the
next 15 years so they're not looking for
a war on taiwan but this certainly makes
it easier for them if they want to
michael bilsby always the best analysis
on anything to do with china we really
appreciate you being with us tonight
thank you so much hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else